oh when I was little I blundered uh my
queen I told my mom that didn't happen
yeah well The Arbiter wasn't there so my
opponent was extremely upset I got away
with it but this for me was the last
because it never improved okay so I
remember one case where I after I lost
the game I was very upset I didn't check
my footstep and this wasn't really fast
I was probably around 10 year old uh and
obviously it was very disrespectful to
him and after the game he told my coach
and my father left and since then I've
always shaken my oppose him win or lose
her I once read a book table my father
was generally very gentle with me but I
got a very serious talking so after that
he came to pick me up from the club and
he saw that and he was not impressed it
was a very good book but that doesn't
excuse me
um I don't know in Norway kids are very
well decided